I'm sorry man it's a 68 billion dollar
project if I could have come to you I
would appreciate if you would submit
your comments we only have about in the
United States history and if I could
have more than a minute of your time I
would really I'm so sorry we don't have
the room hi I'm Scott shackford with
reason.com and recent TV and I am here
with Eric Kristen from the Coalition for
fair employment in construction thanks
for being with us today thanks Scott
your Coalition is involved in California
with what we call project labor
agreements and in particular right now
with what's going on with California's
high-speed rail project so to start with
it tell us a bit about what a project
labor agreement is and why we should be
concerned absolutely they're typically
30 to 60 page documents that govern the
building of any construction project and
when Union what we refer to as unions
put these into place all workers that
work on them have to for all intents and
purposes become Union for the duration
of the project what happens if a
municipality or a developer resists a
project labor agreement what if they
don't want a pla well that's what we
help them do we help provide them with
the insight as to why this isn't a good
deal for them and we provide them
information data empirical evidence
about why these are bad and why they're
harmful and why it will raise their
costs what is the relationship between
project labor agreements and the
high-speed rail that's being developed
here in California union leaders the
connection is in this state despite the
fact that in the construction industry
as in industry as a whole constructions
only represent less than one out of
every five workers the reality is is
they have very deep pockets and in this
state they're very powerful so what they
do is they try and get these placed on
as many projects as possible because you
can imagine non-union workers paying
union dues and pain into Union Health
whole firm pension plans that they will
never benefit from that's free money to
the unions one of the things that really
as you've learned I'm sure with
high-speed rail is the secret level of
secrecy is really remarkable they are
not out front with regards to anything
we really had a dig and we found the
project labor agreement referenced under
you
ISM orwellian if you will of a community
benefit agreement well who could be
opposed to the community benefiting from
something and when we read it it was a
typical PLA that says you have to do all
those things so what they did is they
understood that we've kind of given Pele
as a black ice they didn't want to make
this very public they were hoping it
would just kind of sneak through but we
found it and what you had was the head
of the building and Construction Trades
Council of California sitting on the
high speed rail authority board so we
know where it came from how is your
coach have been responding to the
situation education is the first thing
we're doing last night we had a press
conference that was well attended in San
Diego because San Diego residents need
to understand that even though only 48%
of them supported prop 1a back in 2008
they're being asked to pay the
equivalent of equivalent amount of the
voters in San Francisco that voted 72%
in favor of prop 1a and so education is
a big part of it it is going on most
people are still in disbelief it's even
happening they just thought that this
boondoggle will kind of collapse of its
own weight we are educating them know
it's real it's happening and oh by the
way it also has it as if it needed any
other reason to oppose it it has this
monopoly agreement on it that basically
punishes any worker that's not Union
number two are helping to fund the
lawsuit which on May 31st will be going
to court we believe in the proponents of
this belief that it is in violation of
prop 1a to about six in about six
different instances can you give me a
example of you know the most important
reason to some violation of sure
absolutely this has to make it from Los
Angeles to San Francisco in two hours
and 40 minutes that just simply can't be
done that's number one so they're lying
to people and they say this is a two
hundred and whatever they use two
hundred twenty mile an hour high-speed
rail when when the governor came in
Governor Brown and sawed the price tag
was in excess of a hundred billion
dollars he knew he was in trouble this
thing was taking on water how do we
change it what they did is they went
from a high-speed rail system to what's
known as a blended system where they
have to essentially use Amtrak rails
going through Los Angeles you only get
high speeds when you're in about the
middle of the state and you get up maybe
to 200 miles an hour everywhere else
you're going 70 to 100 miles an hour so
it's not really high speed
ray'll they need to keep saying it goes
220 miles an hour so they can make that
2 hour and 40 minute time workout but it
really doesn't and they say that they
won't have any subsidies for it
unfortunately the governor let the cat
out of the bag and said of course it's
gonna have to be subsidized because our
ridership levels are never gonna be met
therefore we're going to have to have
some subsidies now he cents backtrack
from that but the reality is is
everybody knows is that this isn't going
to be making money it's going to be
taking money if it was going to be
making money Wall Street and the private
sector would be putting money into this
your organization your coalition you
recently attempted to speak at a hearing
in Sacramento about the high speed rail
project what happened at this hearing
well it was something I would imagine
would be akin to what you'd find
happening and you know some kind of
North Korean parliamentary event where
you get up to speak after 59 minutes of
having the bureaucrats speak and say
nothing it was just they had to do this
because the law mandates that they go
before the kind of legislature and say
here's what's going on they spoke for 59
minutes the chairwoman Bonnie Lowenthal
out of Long Beach said well we only have
a minute left where we this room has to
be turned over to another group so we
have a minute of public comments well I
got up I was the first speaker and said
ma'am I'm pologize but the largest
product most expensive project in human
history I think deserves a little bit
more than 30 seconds of our time she we
had a back and forth and essentially
what they did is they tried to shut it
down why stuck I stood around in that
room for an hour and that room will
remained empty finally I left out for an
hour and a half there was no other
meeting there was an attempt to keep the
public out of this not asking any
questions that make it people
uncomfortable and it was really quite
remarkable so they allowed about 30
seconds of public comments on this labor
unions are pretty powerful in California
especially in relationship with the
government how what is your Avenue for
success what a success look like for
your organization in this state where we
really are out manned outgunned and you
know they have pockets that are much
deeper than ours what we do is we really
approach this using a very nonlinear
approach we have to be flexible we have
to be smart we have to be unpredictable
so what we're doing is we're becoming
involved with groups from the left and
the right because this is an
just opposed by if you look at the new
field poll that came out with regard to
where people are in this if it was on
the ballot today prop 1a would go down
60 to 40 Democrats are becoming
increasingly opposed to this Republicans
obviously independents people who just
see this as a boondoggle so what we're
doing is we're reaching out to a broad
cadre of folks and saying this is still
moving forward how can we work together
how can we raise money for the prop 1a
lawsuit how do we keep this in the media
so it's really a nonlinear multifaceted
approach because we don't have the
resources that the other side does okay
well thank you very much for your time
this is Eric Kristen with the Coalition
for fair employment in construction
thank you very much you four reason TV
I'm Scott shackford